What's really cool about those examples,
is that you don't have to know much
about the problem that
you're trying to solve.
All you need is data.
Lot's of data.
And computers.
Lot's of them.
And off you go.
You can build a machine or
any system that often does much
better than specialized,
handcrafted approaches to the problem.
So, here we are.
With those tools in your back pockets,
you can now train models that can
predict from images, texts, sequences,
or any kind of data, for that matter.
If you're curious, there's a ton more
to learn in the field of deep learning.
Things also change every day as
new techniques get developed and
people find new ways
to use those models.
Even with just what you've learned in
this class you have the tools to design
and train real models on real data,
so what are you going to try first?